je suis devant la mairie du 4e
arrondissement pour rencontrer etienne
coubard décrocheurs de portraits des
manuels macro et militants à une v comme
21 bonjour etienne merci de répondre à
nos questions alors nous sommes en
février 2019 et vous décidez avec
plusieurs militants de la rb comme 21 de
décrocher des portraits des manuels
macron comment vous est venue cette idée
racontez nous un peu cette journée
particulière tout d'abord on va dépenser
erevia c'est tout et on est du coup on
s'est déplacé jusqu'à la mairie ici tout
simplement en fait nous sommes montés
jusqu'à là jusqu'à la salle des mariages
où nous avons simplement décrocher ce
portrait puis nous avons fait une photo
à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur puis moi
je suis parti avec en fait en vélo pour
simplement l'homme est donc tout s'est
passé vraiment très tranquillement on
est juste monté et descendu c'était un
geste fort on imagine assez significatif
pour vous pourquoi avoir choisi ce geste
justement c'est un symbole à ses clients
finalement pour la nva coop d'intérêt
même pour vous les experts tels que les
experts du groupe intergouvernemental
sur le climat nous ont alertés sur le
fait qu'on avait besoin d'avoir des
mesures fortes le gouvernement dit on
met en place des mesures en l'occurrence
était pas le cas c'est toujours pas le
cas donc c'est tout simplement pour ça
qu'on a décidé à la fois d'alerté et de
montrer en fait qu'on avait une
nécessité de mettre en place des mesures
fortes
alors par la suite étienne comment ça
s'est passé pour vous sur le plan
judiciaire sur le plan judiciaire donc
six mois après l'action on est allé au
tribunal de paris donc là on a eu une
première une première condamnation dans
lequel on a fait appel et un an après on
était rejugé nouvelle fois ont été
recondamnés est là aujourd'hui on en
cassation pour essayer d'aboutir à une
relaxe donc c'est un peu notre notre
dernière chance entre guillemets on a la
science était du sursis 500 euros
d'amendé ça exactement c'était 500 euros
d'amendé avec sursis pour la première
séance était 100 euros ferme puis celle
des 500 euros avec sursis donc on a eu
un peu moins à la deuxième instance mais
voilà d'autres affaires similaires ont
abouti à des relaxes qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour vous dans l'impression
qu'elle justice un peu à deux vitesses
oui en fait on a eu il ya évidemment des
d'autres procédures dans lequel il ya eu
des relaxes souvent sète hérault
première instance est vraiment jusqu'en
cassation donc elles ont toujours aussi
abouti à un appel de la part de l'état
pour justement recondamné ces activistes
et donc là nous ce qu'on attend
justement comme on arrive en cassation
c'est vraiment d'arriver à aboutir à une
véritable relaxe qu'ils soient donc jugé
en cassation ce qui est la plus haute
juridiction en france quoi quel regard
vous portez sur le décrochage de
portraits aujourd'hui et vous pourriez
leur faire c'est pas notre première
notre première tentative mais
aujourd'hui c'était devenu indispensable
de pouvoir mener une action de
transgresser la loi entre guillemets
pour faire vivre notre message pour
l'exprimer et pour qu'en fait ils
puissent véritablement aboutir à des
actes qu'est ce que vous faites partie
de ces français qui sont en totale
rupture avec emmanuel macron disons que
la rupture avec emmanuel macron s'est
pas particulièrement avec lui en tant
que personne c'est plus aujourd'hui en
fait le gouvernement macron n'est pas à
la hauteur aujourd'hui je dirais pas
qu'il ya un candidat ou une candidate
qui serait à la hauteur en réalité il ya
des mesures qui sont apportées il ya une
franchise à avoir et aujourd'hui elle
est clairement pas du camp d emmanuel
macron ça c'est une certitude on s'est
très clairement en fait si on a le même
mandat macron lors de la prochaine
élection on va aboutir à la même une
action en tout cas là où même mensonge
mm
ou même petite mesure et qui seront pas
à la hauteur mais on aurait besoin
justement d'avoir il ya beaucoup de
programmes qui sont aujourd'hui plus ou
moins à la hauteur à voir aussi si ces
personnes seront aussi en capacité de
pouvoir les mener est ce qu'elle est ce
que c'est aussi tout simplement demandé
des messages de campagne en tout cas on
attend au tournant qui est véritablement
des engagements qu'ils soient pris est
qui et qui passe aussi à l'assemblée et
au sénat